as long as you are living in that world
of expectation you lose take the words
that they're throwing at you that may be
really negative and sultanan hurtful and
just like imagine you have this
invisible shield on you that just likes
reflects it right or like your matrix I
like it's just going over you you don't
feel it so how many things in your life
are you taking for granted what's that
believe nation is Evan my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have Michael Jordan level talent at
something and I want you to find it
embrace it and use it to make a
difference now one of the things I see
in a lot of entrepreneurs is they have a
negative attitude that they hold on to
where if you want to win you got to
embrace the other side you got to let go
of the negativity let go of the negative
people the mindset the belief system is
holding you where you are and so that's
the point in this video we're gonna talk
about the seven ways to destroy your
negative attitude also if you want to
know my strategies and the strategies of
other successful entrepreneurs and how
to build confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you in 30
seconds a five-minute video for free
delivered to your inbox to help you
build unstoppable confidence the link is
in the description below surround
yourself with greatness if you want to
be more confident you need to surround
yourself with things that make you feel
confident realizing that any big
endeavor is the collection of a lot of
small steps that came before if you're
doing work that you love you're more
likely to follow through you're more
likely to do it because it doesn't feel
like work because you love doing it
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with number one
release people from your expectations
this is one that is so crazy
oh it's so crazy so many people are in a
negative spot because they expect other
things from people if you can just
release people from their expectations
you expect your parents to be this way
you expect that person you helped out to
pay you back and be friendly and help
you out in the favor we just expected
the people to do things for us even if
you've given even if the expectation is
deserved holding on to the expectation
holding on to the resentment doesn't let
you go forward I was speaking with a guy
in Boston recently and he comes up to me
and says I do so much work in the
community I volunteer and help out I've
helped so many people build their
initiatives in our community in my city
of Boston and then I tried to build mine
and very few of them came back and
helped me none of them wanted to assist
me and helping me do what I wanted to do
and I've gave them so much I don't get
it I'm I'm pissed off I'm upset as long
as you are living in that world of
expectation you lose
release some of the expectations I
expect nobody to come back and help you
now what now what do you do how do you
build right be happy with that now in
reality you won't have everybody who
doesn't help you but there's gonna be a
lot of people who for their own reasons
like they may not be bad people they're
just busy or they have other things
where the priorities or they didn't see
your email there's lots of reasons but
they just don't want to support you
right now or they can't that's okay I
make tons of videos for free for you
every single day there trying to help
build you up and when I ask for
something like hey can you guys buy my
book or buy my second book or take some
other kind of action most of you don't
even respond most of you don't say no
most of you just don't even reply back
and that's okay that doesn't bother me I
still make videos for you I still do my
best and some of you turn up and some of
you buy ten boxes some of you share with
your friends and some of you are
hardcore fans and I love you and I
appreciate you I'm so grateful for you
but I don't expect that from you either
and so it's putting out and giving out
and enjoying the process and knowing
that you're doing the right
and that doing the right thing is always
the right thing without the expectation
of getting something back using giving
as its own reward instead of only giving
an expectation of receiving that's the
difference because if you're always
living that world of receiving of
expecting of getting something back you
lose you lose you'll always be negative
but the game over you can't be positive
moving forward because just waiting on
somebody else to get back to you when
you're pissed at them as long as you're
pissed and that they get a spot you will
not be productive and moving towards
your dreams so let people go from your
expectations of them way number two is
change your environment the environment
is so important if you around negativity
constantly guess what's gonna happen
you're gonna be negative it's really
hard to be the only positive person in
an entirely negative community and
listen doc that's rough that's for a lot
of people maybe everybody around you is
negative maybe maybe your parents are
negative and your friends are negative
and your aunts and uncles and like
everybody every human being you know is
negative now what do you do how do you
solve that problem I would try to mute
the people I would try to limit exposure
to those people you may not be able to
cut off access to your mom but maybe
limit exposure you don't talk about
certain topics you cut back the number
of hours you spend there and then every
hour you free up you spend time meeting
new people even if it's just online
people even just hanging around Oprah
Winfrey online will shift your
perspective if you spend an hour a day
instead of talking to negative people
and spent that time watching Oprah
Winfrey videos your perspective will
shift your environmental trigger ship
will shift your mindset will make you
more positive will make you more
optimistic especially when consuming
content of people who came from really
negative spot like Oprah Winfrey's
background is ridiculous ridiculously
terrible impoverished not having parents
abuse going to school in potato bags
like just ridiculous that happened to
her and she got to where she is so being
around her positive message from someone
who's gone through exactly what you
might be going through or probably what
she went through is worse than what
you're going through right now is the
mindset shift that you can need so
whether you're actually reaching out and
meeting people local meetups are going
to local events or connecting the local
clubs or doing your best to do outreach
or whether it's just using
aspirational mentors to help you get to
where you need to go shift in your
environment spending less time with
negative people and more time with
positive people will shift your
perspective and make you less negative
too
[Music]
number three is hive empathy when
somebody is coming at you with with a
ton of negativity try to step above it
and just have empathy for their
situation just try to take the words
that they're throwing at you that may be
really negative and insulting and
hurtful and just like imagine you have
this invisible shield on you that just
like reflects it right or like your
matrix tile like it's just going over
you you don't feel it or the words
bounce off and fall on the floor just
just try to avoid the words for a few
seconds and just try to think about that
person think about their life think
about the mindset think about where
they're coming from and think would you
want their life like if you know them if
there's somebody close to you you it's
easy to do you know their life think do
you want their life you know if they're
75 years old and never got to follow
their dream and now we're hating on you
for following your dream like what do
you want to trade spot do you want to be
that person you want to be 75 years old
and have tried your dream and failed and
never got the chance or never took the
chance to go do it again like you don't
want that person's like so you don't
want anything to do with how they think
and so having a little bit of empathy
for where they're coming from allows you
to shift your perspective to say okay
that's why this person is so hateful
like look at their life if you don't
know the person and just just imagine it
so I do this so I did this a lot in the
early days of my youtube channel when I
got a hate comment when somebody would
hate on my video not not because of
anything wrong with the video they just
they hated on me or they hated on the
person I was profiling or they hated on
another
personally even a comment on the channel
and at the start it really bothered me
and I tried to shift the perspective and
I tried to work with them or got really
combative and now I always leap from
place of empathy like can you imagine
somebody coming to your channel leaving
and absolutely hateful comment and
that's how they get satisfaction but
that's how they get a little boost in
their day the thing that gives them a
little bit of energy in the day is is
hating on somebody else's YouTube videos
or hating on somebody else's creative
expression how bad does your life have
to be that that's the highlight of your
day
and I just try to imagine this person
what their life looks like and how I
would never want to step into that
person's life how about an environment
they must have right now and so I feel
sorry for them and having that empathy
can remove the sting of the words
because you still see the words but if
you have a little context of what's
behind the words then it's less likely
to actually sting you even though
they're saying the same words we number
four is change your routine you were a
product of your environment and your
routines you're a product of what you do
every day so if you wake up one day and
you're negative and one day that you're
you're positive and then next day you're
negative and next you're negative again
but there's no consistency in your
routine and a lot of people wake up like
an accident a lot of people wake up and
they have no plan they have no routine
they fall into their day they they wake
up and they check their phone and now
you're just immediately responding to
other people's emergencies through email
and social media you have no set to find
routine and so you just take on
everybody else's agenda for your time
block that off like you got to do the
thing in the morning that gets you
feeling positive this great exercise to
go through think about when you felt the
most positive the most bold the most
alive the most courageous and just
dissect what happened before were you
watching a video we're reading the book
we having a conversation where you hug
in your cat were you at the gym like
what were you doing that gets you into a
positive mindset if for example it's
dancing dancing it makes you feel happy
dancing shifts your mood immediately
into a positive one great start every
morning dancing wake up put on your
playlist and drive it in put on the song
that automatically makes you want to be
happy and dance and pick a couple songs
as the same song won't work forever save
a rotation of songs or if it's watching
a video there's tons of videos or
between the book there's tons of books
listen to podcast is tons of podcast
start your day with the thing that makes
you feel positive because if you wake up
feeling negative there aren't that many
people wake up and like yes what a day I
can't wait for this day to start right
here you wake up on your tires you might
have had a bad sleep most people wake up
neutral and so if you do the thing that
then allows you to have a positive
viewpoint on life and do that with
intention schedule the first 10 15
minutes of your day with intention you
are much more likely to achieve that
intention where if you have no intention
you much more likely to just respond to
everybody else's needs for you
time and dive down into really negative
spot way number five to destroy your
negative attitude is to have gratitude
it's really hard to be really grateful
for something a negative at the same
time think about how fortunate you are
to live your life think about like you
have internet access you can watch this
video you know you're growing up if
you're in North America you have nothing
to complain about compared to a lot of
other places in this world and so just
having some gratitude for the health of
the people around you for the country
that you live in for the area that we
still get to breathe that you can look
out a window and still see trees I try
to mix it up between something big like
I get to do this amazing work I get to
help entrepreneurs I just came back from
Boston and helped all these people like
something kind of mission driven
something family like I'm so grateful
for my wife and my parents and they're
still alive and we're all healthy and my
dogs and they're amazing they give me
energy and fun every day and it's
something that is easy to miss right why
do people love rainbows so much and they
never notice the sunrise or sunset
because the rainbow is rare because the
rainbow doesn't happen all the time like
wow look at the rainbow
but you don't often say wow look at that
sunset but it happens every day you're
awake you work every single day when the
Sun sets maybe the Sun rises too but you
take it for granted because it's just
happening so how many things in your
life are you taking for granted so I
will be grateful for
you know this table these tables amazing
it's like the perfect height right just
to hold my book everything is awesome
I'm grateful for this hoodie I love this
hoodie right it allows the mic to be
clipped perfectly on the zipper because
my other hoodie is just a turtleneck and
it's harder to put them like those kinds
of things being grateful for seemingly
insignificant things but it actually
adds value to my life and so mixing that
between that between something big we
should give them between family and
personal connections and relationships
and then something seemingly
insignificant and small that is the
hidden beauty is the sunset and sunrise
set of only looking for the rainbows
it's really hard to be grateful for
what's happening your life ain't
negative at the same time so to
eliminate the negativity inject a little
more gratitude
[Music]
wait number six to destroy your negative
attitude is to do work you love when you
get to do work that you love it's really
hard to be negative right and it doesn't
mean that every day is amazing I wake up
and I do work that I love but there's
still there's still moments in the still
days that are bad where just chaos
happens things blow up didn't go as
planned I fail my team fails we make
mistakes all over the place that still
happens but net I get to do work that I
love where if you're doing work that you
hate it's really hard to wake up and be
happy when you're doing work that you
hate you have to force yourself everyday
to think okay why how am i grateful for
this crappy job how my group over this
terrible boss what lessons am i learning
to all this the mental exercise you have
to force yourself through and so doing
work that you love or at least making a
plane to get to the work that you love
if you want to eventually be an
entrepreneur then at least pick an
industry where you can learn from it you
have the job that's giving you the
skills so you can map to you becoming
that entrepreneur that you want as it
was sustained this job that you really
really really really really really
really hate and so you don't say they
have to burn the boats quit your job
throw supper on your boss's office so
that there's no chance to you ever
coming back but if you're not doing work
that you love at least having a plane to
work towards it whether that that plan
happens this week next week three months
a year like you're working towards
making that plan happen and if you're
seeing progress you've seen hope it's a
lot easier to be happy during the day
where if you feel like you're stuck in
this job doing work you hate forever and
ever and amen it's really hard if you
happen to be a really happy person
[Music]
anyway number seven to destroy your
negativity is to know and live your one
word I think one of the biggest reasons
why people aren't happy is they don't
know themselves they have zero self
awareness and if you don't know yourself
your one word is your most important
core value if you don't know what it is
then you end up live in somebody else's
life you end up taking on other people's
values when somebody tells you can you
do this or please do that or you have to
do this you will end up wanting to do it
because they have confidence in that
thing and you don't have any confidence
in yourself if you don't know what you
stand for then you don't know what you
stand against you have no walls and so
people will walk all over you and it may
feel wrong or may feel like you have a
lot more potential inside you doesn't
necessarily mean you're in the mud
doesn't mean like you hate your life
completely but self-awareness for me is
the big factor I think when you know
yourself when you know your most
important core value when you know what
that stands for
then it allows you to create a business
and a life that is with intent that is
purposeful that is meaningful and the
people who don't fit in who don't have a
similar value to you who don't believe
the things that you believe you will
never be happy working with them and so
if you have the awareness to know what
you're saying for what you stand against
then those people kind of bounce off you
and they can go off and do something
else it's just not with you and doesn't
mean they're bad people they can be
amazing people just not amazing with you
so let then go off and do that thing
instead of keeping them kind of
infecting into your life when you have
that stability it's like the rock solid
foundation when you have the rock solid
foundation of what you stand for your
one word your most important core value
then it allows you to build that path
with confidence which will allow you to
be happy and purposeful and meaningful
so that's my take on the seven ways to
destroy your negative attitude I would
love to know which of the seven was the
most meaningful to you and why is there
an eight nine ten you want to add to the
list let me know in the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
altruistic
world domination honey Empire right I'm
grateful
I understand why I'm here I think
because I am so open I wanted to think
and see it's a bloody brief life all of
you have the potential for enormous
success if you want to know what garyvee
DJ khalid oprah and others know about
empire building that most people miss
check out the link in the description
for a free bonus video